How many of you have ever walked
into a room and wondered,
“Why did I come here in the first place?”
Or maybe you left something behind,
your pencil case, for example,
and you have to circle the entire house
before coming back to the place
where you originally started
only to find it sitting right there?
Anyone had any similar experiences?
Great.
Fo me, it’s things like
this that define my life.
My friends know me for continuously losing
my water bottle, among other things.
I am, in every sense of the word,
a scatterbrain.
And I was feeling pretty foolish
about it myself
until I read this article
about this book called,
“Where Good Ideas Come From:
The Natural History of Innovation."
And in it, the author Steven Johnson
compares settlements of different types,
so like cities and towns,
noting that as cities get bigger,
they generate ideas at a faster clip.
Why? Because of the increase in the number
of ideas in a fixed area.
So in our context,
a scatterbrain can be seen
as a metropolis with bits
of disorganized information
floating around,
constantly crashing into each other.
It's messy.
But it is also more likely
for two unrelated ideas to collide
giving rise to new innovations,
like hip-hop – ballet fusion
or the use of math to formulate
a harmonic melody.
So in essence, a scatterbrain then,
becomes a source
of creativity and innovation
and therefore,
it's just as Steven Johnson said:
“The more disorganized your brain is,
the smarter you are.”
Now, considering that I had the potential
of being the queen of scatterbrains,
I was feeling pretty good about myself.
But another part of me
started to wonder,
“Hold up. If you’re such a genius then how
come none of your ideas ever take shape?”
And that brings us to the greatest
disaster faced by all scatterbrains:
flooding.
It happens internally and externally.
Let me explain.
Now, I don’t know about you,
but 90% of the best ideas I have ever had
have come to me when I’m in the shower.
So, I might have an English Literature
essay due the next day,
and I might be shampooing my hair when all
of a sudden this line pops up in my head
"Despite his high status,
Othello, the tragic hero,
eventually falls to his doom due
to jealousy – his greatest hamartia."
And I'm like "Yes! This will make
a top-notch literature sentence."
So I quickly finish showering,
get my clothes on,
seat myself at my table,
pen and paper in hand,
ready to write that golden essay.
And I reach into my head to find that line
only to find lyrics
to a Michael Jackson song
or images from the last movie I watched.
In the end I’m just left there thinking,
“Hmm, I had this really nice way of saying
Othello dies. What was it again?"
My mind is so flooded that I can’t
find that sentence
I came up with just two minutes ago!
The second type of flooding
happens externally
by people putting things in your brain.
So, for example, I might be
on my way to school and my mom would say,
"Hey, why don't you buy this chocolate
from this particular shop
because apparently,
it tastes really good."
And then I'd go to school
and I'd get attacked
by an arsenal of math equations.
And then I might go to lunch
and my friends would give
me this list of movies
to remember to watch over the weekend.
And the day would go on and on
with things piling in my head
until finally,
it looked something like this.
This, my friends, is what
a scatterbrain looks like.
All those pieces of paper are bits of
information that people put in your brain.
And sometimes they go in,
sometimes they don’t.
And in this mess, the chances of
remembering to look at the information
that says “remember your bottle,”
well, that's pretty slim.
Yet, strangely enough,
my memory becomes flawless
when it came to things like remembering
dialogues from a movie,
or random facts,
for example, did you know that
the word for pineapple
in a lot of the languages of the world
sound something like “ananas?"
So, for example, in Hindi, its “ananas,"
in French its “ananas,",
in Indonesian it's “nanas."
It's a completely useless fact,
like I'm probably never going to use it,
maybe I might, I don't know,
but I remember it super clearly.
And that got me thinking, "Why?"
Why is it I can remember
the translation for pineapple,
but I can’t remember a sentence
I came up with just two minutes ago?
Forget that, I can’t even remember
not to leave my water bottle behind!
So after a lot of frustration
and contemplation,
I was able to condense it down
into three main points:
sequence,
association,
and iteration,
S.A.I.
What does it mean?
Well, sequence is your ability to find
a logical pattern
in the information
you have to remember.
Association is when you link that
information with something
weird, striking, memorable
to make it stick in your brain,
and iteration is when you repeat it
so many times
that it automatically
gets stuck in your head.
That's why when I go,
"Hello, can you hear me?"
I bet half of the people in this room
are able to sing along
because they've heard it 1,000 times.
Or when I say the word "frozen,"
you immediately think of a blonde girl
in a blue dress
singing, "Let it go, let it go."
Your brain is able to pick up
that specific information
and display it at the right moment.
So that's for things we don't really
need to remember.
How about the things
that are really required?
Well, we apply the same three rules.
In fact, man has been
using it throughout history.
Before the time of writing,
there was the oral tradition
where the history of civilizations
was passed down through songs and hymns.
Forget history, think about yourself!
Back in nursery,
your teachers used nursery rhymes
to teach you things like alphabets,
parts of the body, numbers.
All these rhymes had sequence,
could be associated
with something interesting,
and if it was iterated enough times,
it will automatically
get stuck in your head.
The first time I was formally introduced
to memory techniques
was when I was in sixth grade,
and I was going through a phase
where I had somehow gotten it into my head
that I could not continue living
unless I learned Japanese.
So one day, I was in the kitchen with
my mom who was cooking,
and I was trying to learn the numbers
one to ten in Japanese.
Emphasis on the word trying.
I.e. I was going nowhere.
But I wasn't about to give up
anytime soon,
so I was rambling on and on,
and my mom must have gotten fed up
because at one point,
she gently interrupted me
and she was like,
"Trishna, why don't you make
a story out of it?"
And I was like, 'Mother, how the heck am
I supposed to make a story out of this?"
And she was like,
"Okay, think of it this way.
One in Japanese is ichi and two is ni.
Together, they sound something like
an itchy knee."
And I was like, "Okay,
I see what you did there."
And I went ahead
and I created a story of my own.
And it goes something like this:
Once upon a time,
there was a kid named Meg.
Now Meg, had a very "ichi ni."
And it was a very "san"ny day,
so she was feeling really sleepy
and she began to "yon" a lot.
So to wake herself up, she decided
to "go" out and play,
so she went outside and she started
playing with some "rokus,"
but then she decided "nana,"
I've got to stop because it had begun
raining and she had caught a cold
and she was sneezing like, "hachi!"
So, she went to find shelter in
the nearest store, but when she got there,
she found a really long "kyuu,"
but the shop owner who was this "jew"
and he was really nice
and he let her go in first.
The end.
It's a completely weird useless story
but that's kind of what made it stick.
There was a sequence of events,
I associated each word with a homophone,
and if I repeat it enough times, it will
automatically get stuck in my brain.
Perfect, right?
With a technique like this,
I could remember anything!
Unfortunately, no.
I couldn't remember things when I didn't
remember that I had something to remember,
my water bottle, for instance.
So while I was excelling in class,
where I had to remember things
like lists and definitions,
outside, I was still a complete mess.
And then, when I entered junior high,
the BBC Sherlock Holmes TV show came out,
and its protagonist, Sherlock Holmes,
had the one thing I had always longed for,
an awesome memory.
He called it his "mind palace."
He could do this thing
where within a matter of seconds,
he could come out with the exact date,
place and time
a murder happened 20 years ago.
I was blown away.
So I did the first thing any girl
of my generation would do; I Googled him.
And I found out that his memory technique
was quite a commonly used one
called the Method of Loci.
It uses what's known as spatial memory,
which is your ability to remember
geographical spaces in detail.
So, for example, you know every
nook and cranny in your room,
or maybe something bigger,
you know all the roads in a certain area.
So when I found out I was ecstatic
and I wanted to put it to immediate use.
And the most current problem
I was having at the time
was my tendency to lose things
I was carrying with me,
my water bottle, for instance.
So I developed a routine wherein
before leaving a place,
I would take a walk around school
in my head.
What do I mean?
Well, the first step to creating
a mind palace
is picking a location
you are really familiar with,
and for me, personally,
I know all the rooms in my school,
so I made the school my mind palace.
And I associated each room
with objects I tended to lose a lot.
So, for example, the calculator
I would associate with the math room,
my USB with the computer room,
and my bottle with the lost and found,
and on and on,
So before leaving a room, I would mentally
take a walk around each of these rooms
and check to see if I had the associated
object on me at the time.
So for example, I would first go to the
math room associated with the calculator-
Do I have it? Yes, and then move on
the next rooms
checking to see if I had each object
until finally I reached the lost and found
associated with the bottle-
Do I have the bottle? Yes. Complete.
Obviously, this is a highly simplified
version of the actual thing,
but it's one way
of putting the technique to use.
And here, too, we can see S.A.I.
We can see the sequence of rooms,
and how each room is associated
with an object,
and if I walk through these rooms
enough times,
all of it will automatically get stuck
in my head.
So that's the bottle problem solved.
And I also manage
to retain my scatterbrain genius
of being able to find anything I need
in the metropolitan mess of my mind
using these memory techniques.
So let's come back to the present.
Hello everyone.
My name's Trishna, I am 17-years old,
and I am a complete scatterbrain,
but I manage my life pretty well using
my new and refined memory techniques.
Well, it's not 100% foolproof,
but at least I can say with confidence
I will never have to ask myself
this question again.
Thank you.